wir haben gerade schon gehört die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind natürlich
immens du bist jetzt vor ort was genau
wird dort alles gemacht um dafür zu
sorgen dass es nichts passiert guten
morgen etwas richtig gesagt ganz europa
schaut heute nach magdeburg aber man
muss leider sagen die sachsen
anhaltinische justiz hatte wohl
scheuklappen auf bei der vorbereitung
denn wenn man jetzt mal hier hinter mich
schaut steht etwa eine dreiviertel
stunde vor dem offiziellen beginn des
prozesses immer noch der großteil der
öffentlichkeit in der schlange also
dieser sicherheitskonzept hat wohl dazu
geführt dass hier eine massive
verstopfung eingetreten ist bei der
sicherheitsschleuse also es kommt kaum
jemand voran es kommen immer neue
nebenkläger insgesamt sind ca 43
nebenkläger die von über 20 anwälten
vertreten werden die hier auch erst mal
vorrang haben bevor sie in diesem saal
kommen an sicherheitsvorkehrungen hat es
investitionen gegeben 300.000 euro
wurden vom land sachsen-anhalt zur
verfügung gestellt man hat diese
allerdings heute formal heute vormittag
vor allen dingen beim transport des
angeklagten hierher nach magdeburg
bemerkt er seinem helikopter von burg
auf dem flugplatz nach magdeburg
gebracht wurden und um 8.05 hier etwa
100 meter von mir entfernt ein konvoi
aus acht fahrzeugen und einem motorrad
mit stephan pariert in die zufahrt zum
landgericht und brachte den angeklagten
hier vor ort ob jetzt allerdings um 10
tatsächlich alles planmäßig beginnen
kann das steht im moment sehr in den
sternen was kannst du uns denn bereits
über die über den richter und auch über
die verteidiger sagen die jetzt am
prozess beteiligt sind
die vorsitzende richterin der
staatsschutzsenat es ist so lehrt es
eine sehr erfahrene richterin seit 20
jahren in der justiz in sachsen anhalt
tätig hatte zum beispiel auch schon mit
dem mit dem könig von deutschland im
selbsternannten peter fitzek zu tun
sie sitzt dem staatsschutzsenat des olg
naumburg vor
zusammen mit vier anderen richtern
schöpfen gibt es hier in seinem
verfahren nicht wo die
bundesanwaltschaft die anklage erhebt
zwei bundesanwälte werden die sehr 16
seiten lange anklageschrift verlesen und
danach wird dann der angeklagte
gelegenheit haben sich einzulassen ich
konnte kurz vor behandlungsbeginn mit
thomas rutkowski sprechen das ist ein
ganz kurzfristig neu hinzugekommener
wahlverteidiger von stefan ballett aus
seinem heimatort helbra und er hat mir
gesagt er hat also gestern erst noch mit
seinem mandanten gesprochen er habe sich
sehr intensiv mit der akte befasst und
haben sich auf eine längere einlassung
vorbereitet ich habe ihn gefragt ob die
vernehmungen beim bundesgerichtshof nach
seiner festnahme im oktober wo er vier
stunden lang ausgepackt hat ob das so
ungefähr eine richtschnur sei und sagt
ja da würde er wohl ran kommen können er
hat also auch schriftliche aufzeichnung
mitgebracht ich habe ihn auch gefragt ob
er diesen auftritt hier nutzen wird
seine provokation man weiß ja über die
vorbilder von stephan balga trennten
talent aus neuseeland oder anders
breivik der seinen prozess ja zu gesten
genutzt hat zur provokation so
propaganda und er hat mich nur der
verteidiger hat mich nur an gegrinst und
gesagt lassen sie sich mal überraschen
und ich glaube das ist es tatsächlich
was auch mit einem unguten gefühl die
nebenkläger hier erwarten dass stefan
bald hier eine show draus machen könnte
wir müssen uns darüber auf jeden fall
auf dem laufenden halten vielen dank